this talk- depend on those but for
Brendan thank you and thank you for
showing up thanks for the organizers to
and well during this semester you've
already heard a few talks about
Lorentzian Paulo members under different
names maybe NEMA and his collaborators
call it have : Corinthian polynomials no
sorry completely low concave polynomials
but the one who started studying in
studying them was Leonid goob it's and
he called them strongly low concave but
they should be called so but today I'll
try to zoom in on one topic that we
brought up in our paper namely negative
dependence and what lawrencium
polynomials has to say about that and
may be fitting for this workshop is that
I will focus on the random cluster model
or the q Potts the q state Potts model
okay
so we will be looking at discrete
probability measures so we have a
discrete probability probability measure
mu
on the collections of subsets of a
finite set e purposes
and then we want to we want to
investigate negative dependence
properties and we do that through the
multivariate rajesh partition function
so we have the partition function Xenu
which is sum over all subsets
take X to the X today the product of all
the variables that are this is a
multivariate multi affine polynomial all
variables appear at most of the power
what so then what is positive and
negative diplomas
so positive dependence tries to remodel
attracting particles
[Applause]
think of having particles at each of
these sites index by E and then positive
dependence models attracting particles
in terms of properties of MU and then
negative dependence so maybe the
simplest instance of positive and
negative dependence is positive and
negative correlations so patients or
pairwise correlations the probability to
probability that eg are present or is
greater or equal to the product of the
individual probabilities is present this
is the probability that we will see if
the these events were were independent
but since we have some attracting
particles they want to create a
probability of both our presence hmm so
we have some attractions and the same
thing with negative
negative correlations that my week we
have the opposite side
mm-hmm and we also have so these are
rather weak positive dependence and
negative dependence properties but and
we can get stronger if we look at
positive Association instead this is the
property that expectation product of two
functions should be greater or equal to
the product of the expectations this
should hold for increasing functions
and the same negative negative curl
negative association is a that's a bit
more subtle inequality holds
FNG but depending on
so what I mean by that is that we can
partition the set E into two sets and F
only depends on one of the sets and G
depends on the complement of the chords
hmm okay so
so how would we in terms of the
partition function this positive and
negative
relations with vertical so the
probability that I is present well this
is this is what we get if we
differentiate the partition function
with respect to I because then all the
terms that do not contain I disappears
and we're left with once that contain so
so so these correlations are can be
interpreted as a quality of the
partition function namely that
or shall I to denote the partial
derivative with respect to I
but then the positive and negative
correlations are are interpreted as
business this inequality differential
equality where when we look at the
vector of all box and if we look at some
other vector we also get positive and
negative correlations but for the
measure where we expose some where we
impose some external field with positive
hmm so what is the random cluster model
so it was introduced by fault alarm yes
so we have some graph
G finite set and then we have some
parameter cube
which is zero so here in this talk
q does not have to be an integer but it
can be any real positive number so and
then we define a measure by by saying
that probability of a single chance
well opposite eight is proportional to
the product so we have weights to so we
have weights W positive for each
I mean
and I would take Q to the number of
connected components a obeys the number
of connected components wrapped with
with edges
in distress
otherwise it will be trivial
hmm so this is the random cluster model
and it's also the the Q Pops model where
we have this external field so we've
seen that yes
okay so for let's have a look at so so
for 4q less than one this yeah this
random just amount of favors few
connected components 4q great on the one
it it it wants to have many
and so this sort of hints to that that
4q less than one it should be negative
dependent and 4q greater than one it
should be positive and more maybe this
is more easy to see there if we look at
the quotient than the this external
field disappears then we only get Q to
the
and now hmm this is a super modular
function so so we will get
less than or equal to one
if it's greater than one and it's if I
got the science right and I think I did
and under there is a famous theorem by
Vuitton and castellane and Ginebra who
namely the f.k.d theorem
so this says that if if this property
holds that that the topless is less than
or equal to the bottom and this is
called the negative lattice condition if
this holds then the measure is actually
positive positively associated so so
this says that for and direct
consequence is that for Q greater than
one is positively no succeed so this is
easy Q greater than minus is in this
respect but for so long standing
conjecture is that for Q less than 1 nu
is
negativity depends
what do I mean by that well so this is
maybe loose conjecture but it should be
in particular it should be it should
have negative associations and more
weakly it should yeah we should it
should satisfy negative correlations
and it should shut up
okay but where sin equality doesn't help
no no this is more for well I guess well
it was only proved for for product
measures and well now now they prove it
for more so and in the only the
supermajority metal structures important
so say have any function Q two is any
function which is so experimental so
only that matters yeah so it's only they
did this negative lattice condition
positive lattice condition is right
about here so this is a very general
theory well easy to apply so you only
need is very local theorem implies
global theorem like possible uses it
it's a very applicable well if very
useful in many situations this is not a
local condition and super majorities
like laxity
this is no no you can see that it's
actually only need to to look at Paris
often to define it locally
so we will talk about zeros of partition
functions in this workshop so
so many of these instances yourself-
dependence can be proven by by looking
at the serials of the multivariate
partition functions this is a theorem
that ten years old
[Music]
hmm and it says that if if if we have a
measure new and Xenu is stable meaning
that see me with non-vanishing
whenever
whenever the imaginary parts of the
variables are positive my man
the MU is negatively associated and many
more products so it satisfy most
versions of negative dependence that you
can think of so this is a very very
powerful class and you can you can prove
a lot of negative and dependence
properties from this however it is not
you can see quickly see that it's not
applicable to this case I think you're
only four sort of trees if you have a
cycle then you screwed so so what do we
how do you want to do it where for for
which we can look at this easy lemma we
have a polynomial P with no negative
coefficients
which is
on Venus
a quadratic
then the following the following so the
first is that the fee is stable
how the other one is that if we write P
as a
keep it up they would be like me that
Hashem
then this matrix arg should have exactly
one positive I cannot
as a cost one positive
well because it has no negative
coefficients then if it's not entirely
zero or come then then it has a poor
pairen eigenvalue so it has some
positive eigenvalue and if it's a non
singular then it has the Lorentz
signature meaning that it has exactly
one positive eigenvalue and the rest of
the eigenvalues are negative this is
where these corinthian polynomials
prepared for us but if it's non singular
as iessons
so what are we first defined strictly
around same polynomials which is that
gonna be a good set of polynomials
yes
Renault Megane across
strictly your answer first all possible
possible coefficients are positive and
by possible I mean that we will already
have the constraints that it's on a
genius of degree D so all positive
possible coefficients should be positive
and more importantly that whenever you
differentiate your polynomial along the
coordinate axis D minus 2 times you
should get a polynomial of this type
namely a stable polynomial or a strictly
stable palanca
or a matrix with symmetric matrix with
Laurent signature
for all
for Taiwan - to positive engineer for
non-negative integers
the polynomial quadratic
[Music]
I say this is a metric matrix then it
has the Lawrence
exactly one positive eigenvalue and the
rest of the eigenvalues are negative
does that make sense the right
definition hmm so we you can see there's
an best strictly rounding polynomials
are the polynomials with coefficients
are positive and whenever you sort of
whenever whenever you project it down to
a quadratic you using derivatives then
you get a polynomial with a well
quadratic with the Laurent signature
which is equivalent by this lemma to to
being sort of a stable power strictly
stable polynomial so it is indeed a it
is indeed a relaxation of this property
of being state we shall see that it is a
rather nice
yes
okay so what is the Laurentian
polynomial
oh sure of the set of strict lawrencium
polynomials who have be called this
space of Lorenzi polynomial so a
polynomial Romeo is LeBron seein if it
is the limit
okay
let us Kemp maybe
that's hard to see that we can get a
nice characterization of of 'quran
simple animal yeah it's a matter of
taste if you it could be zero yeah
identically zero hmm but usually varma
one looks at this projected li and then
we can
so yes so let's look at some so by just
looking at this definition now so when I
say we have a
I'll have a bivariate polynomial
we have all the positive coefficients
now and this is run soon
if and only if
[Applause]
and why is that well what is the
definition the definition is that is
strictly so the definition is that all
the coefficients should be positive well
this we assume that but so we only have
to check when when we take when we
different differentiate down to
quadratic but if we differentiate down
to quadratic we are going to get exactly
these coefficients but with a two in
front of the a K so they so being so
this quadratic being stable is this is
the same as well this the corresponding
matrix have any exactly most one
positive have exactly one positive eigen
values X equivalent them to this 2x2
matrix having negative determinant
should have one positive eigen value and
one negative eigenvalues of the
corresponding 2x2 matrix should have
negative determinant and this is exactly
what you get and some of you should
recognize this gurus does
these are the Neutron inequalities or
ultra log concavity you turn
inequalities which are satisfied by
polynomials with the only real zeros
univariate polynomials with only three
in series so so for bivariate
polynomials which could be seen as a
fine univariate polynomials then the
lorentz strictly lawrencium property is
equivalent to satisfying the Newtonian
equalities which is a sort of a nice
relaxation of the class of real rooted
polynomials and this will be useful for
us
okay so in order to work with these
Lorentzian polynomials we want to get a
nice equivalent condition this we want
to define what an M convex set or a
collimator ODIs so that collection of
vectors
so a finite collection of integer
vectors is a n convex set
or the basis of a polymer code the
following
that's the hope so alpha and beta Jake
mm-hmm and any
and if any index so that the coordinate
in alpha is less than the coordinate in
beta
and there is there is an index J such
that instead alpha J is greater than
coordinate in alpha is greater than
coordinate in beta and such that we can
move towards from kalfa to beta in two
steps so we get so alpha here
so yeah so in other words we should have
that out so we should get oh sorry we
don't sorry
we don't need this
so we should be able to to go two steps
and then fall into the to the this.j
again so that alpha plus ETA minus EJ
isn't GE j again so let's take this
again because it got a bit confused so
an M comic set is such that the
following sort of basis exchange change
axiom hold so that if if one if the
output coordinate is less than the beta
coordinate for some I then we should
find another index J with greater alpha
coordinate so that we can move so that
we can add one step in the ice
coordinate and subtract one one in the
eighth coordinate so we appear in the
set again so if you think about 0 1 if J
is just say one vectors then this is
equivalent to the bases exchange taxi
for matrix so that's why it's called
equivalence
okay
now characterize
so a polynomial with non-negative
coefficients is lawrencium if and only
if so first
the support of of f support of the
polynomial P which by definition is the
so that the support so it's Laurentian
if and only if the support is a Polaroid
Natori or Commission and the next
condition is done that the relaxation of
that the projections should be have the
Lorenson signature so they at most to
close the corresponding close property
of having Lauren signature that you have
positive eigenvalues are positive
coefficients yes so we defined it an
open condition so that we don't so this
is then non-trivial to to sort of see
that if you so what kind of supports do
you get when you don't require well well
when you relax this property and what
you get is actually exactly the M
complex function so there's a converse
to this that any polyMet road is it's
gonna appear as the mm at the support of
her honor M comics so conversely
so conversely conversely the if if J is
a polyMet road and come back set then
the this the generating polynomial
suitably scaled is Lorenson
so this class of of polynomials is
intimately connected to poly matrix and
matrix
another property which is important is
that it's closed down there and their
changes linear changes of variables
where the corresponding matrix is non
negative is Laurentian
a is a matrix suitable matrix with
non-negative coefficients
and if we do this change of variables
then versus fluorescein again hmm
so if we have a low-ranking polynomials
then we can for example set identify a
bunch of of the variables so that we
come down to acquire to a polynomial of
a bivariate polynomial and then this
bivariate polynomial has to satisfy the
the these neutron inequalities so I said
it should be suitable so so that it
should have if if P has n variables it
should have n columns but otherwise so
no no so we start by by proving this
actually this one because this one
allows you see the main beauty of this
it changes you should wait to - yes this
is sort of how we do it we but we yeah
how I was dealing you wanted the word
complex analysis we can collect some
more properties so so if we apply so
hmm okay and we also have this that if
he is and we have this almost negative
correlations so we have the IP times so
if we take P times D IJ P then this is
less than or equal to two times so we
almost have negative correlations but we
have to pay the price of a two
okay so how does this all apply to the
random cluster model well so if if we
now have a random cluster if mu is a
random cluster module model with Q less
than or equal to 1 then then the
partition function is actually
Florencia homogenized inequality does it
hold on all right
sorry
sorry you cannot see this right now you
can see it there so okay homogeneous the
polynomial the partition function of the
random cluster model for Q less than one
then then this is this is indeed
lawrencium so what do we get we cannot
prove the the negative correlation con
negative correlation conjecture but we
can almost prove it we can prove it with
the two but we get the non-trivial fact
that we get is that there the rank of
the
the rank generating polynomial is
satisfied Newton's inequalities which is
also a desirable negative dependents
property so let's press this so again
with the same hypothesis test before if
you know our K is the probability that
they said a has size K
yeah
then Newtonian equalities for this party
which is
sometimes a useful property of you for
example when I look at when convergence
into the normal distribution this is
usually enough to prove convergence
ah thanks
so here n is number the number of edges
[Applause]
since we since we this is the beauty of
it all that so one of the defining
properties is that the support is a is a
matrix or a poly Metroid and poly mate
matrix and pollinators are closed under
taking conditioning or so in
conditioning is the same as taking
partial derivatives so we only have to
put yeah so all the these matrix
questions that we can solve with this we
just have to prove for for a rank 2
matrix and rank two major roads are very
simple they are just like but this is
also look like if you differentiate with
respect to a you you well-to-do variable
here you get a you get a random cluster
model for there for one edge contracted
right
[Music]
so it's homogeneous case there is this
equivalent way to say what is Paloma
Tori right whole like inequalities so
can you go straight to the things which
is kind of in my opinion easier to
understand that the system so that there
is discrimination yeah more directly
with the things which is almost like you
know it feels almost like proper tragic
situation is what we get so this this is
a Paula Metroid but yeah but instead of
working with the job you use death yeah
yeah yeah but this is equivalent this is
easy so but yeah you could you could
work with that instead I think but
they're all the same
yep
[Music]
so the ending binomial logarithm of this
is concave
for the making the substitution X I have
P - D Y I and then looking at the
function is why I am what - stability
there what is the statement about
stability so you do the substitution and
loggia squanders know they have that's
one theorem the Hessian is so there's a
large class of so these stable
polynomials they satisfy this with a
with the constant factor bomb here
but I think what you were talking about
we depended on them and non-negativity
coefficients no it also required
convexity of the partition function of
three paths but that only requires non
negativity of coefficients the problem
every service for them it's not you
don't need polynomials better you have
exactly quality but it's because someone
who come back ones work all the girls in
the post wanted the sale then you have
the reverse real stable inequality for
any specific polynomial for all vectors
the first the reverse assuming you want
greater or equal to here listen this is
sort of a special case of the this
negative lattice condition which is very
common in
a third wishes not let us thanks it
stricter gun 10:30